et c'est un mythe est une femme je
disais c'est une invitée eux et c'est
une des rares femmes en france qu'ils
soient chefs avec deux étoiles vous êtes
on est 2e avec anne sophie pic de ça
c'est très rare vous arrivez du sud
ouest c'était à villeneuve de marsan que
votre père avait déjà un relais et
châteaux avait un relais châteaux dans
le sud-ouest à villeneuve de marsan dans
les landes donc j'ai travaillé avec lui
pendant trois quatre ans quand même je
travaillais là bon alors le père était
dans la partie le grand père aussi la
quatrième génération dario tempère 4
c'était presque génétique et la bon
c'était quand même idée de votre père de
vous ménager photo parce que non j'ai
fait ce type de course et passe à ça je
crois que wade je crois que papa avait
beaucoup plus envie que ce soit mon
frère qui soient un jour cuisinier que
moi maintenant je crois qu'il année très
très heureux et c'est vrai qu'au départ
moi j'ai fait des études de commerce et
c'est après avec la maturité on réalise
qu'on a une passion et que c'est mieux
de la vivre on fait quoi alors vous ai
fait un stage chez ducasse plus qu'un
stage je ne suis resté pendant presque
trois ans chez ducasse va tellement en
cuisine un pli dans ses bureaux qu'en
cuisine je suis resté trois mois en
cuisine simplement et c'est alain
ducasse qui après ma m'a dit allez
mettez vous derrière le piano l ai dit à
quel moment vous êtes senti que c'était
votre truc
en fait gentiment moi depuis toujours je
cuisine et un je t'assure de cause
justement de tous mes copains étaient
très contents d'être confiants avec moi
parce que c'est elle est donc donc j'ai
toujours eu envie de cuisiner j'ai
toujours cuisiné j'ai toujours été très
très gourmand mais alors on voit en
voilà des images de joux en cuisine avec
un beau chapeau d'ailleurs donc votre
restaurant il et audace
voilà c'est ça on est venu vous
installer à paris vous avez conquis la
votre deuxième étoile
voilà ce qui est quand même assez
exceptionnel en cuisine vous avez
combien de
personne aujourd'hui n'est à pâtisserie
contourner emmené une vingtaine à
travailler en cuisine aujourd'hui bon et
quand on est femme pour n'est pas très
grande majorité ça me pose aucun
problème je crois qu'à mes
collaborateurs non plus en général ça se
passe très très bien l'autorité elle se
fait dans la discussion dans le respect
de l'autre dans l'eure et puis toujours
montré l'exemple
cinq mille autres bateaux la cuisine
j'ai eu la chance de naître dedans je
quelqu'un comme pierre troisgros m'a
fait sauter sur ses genoux donc donc
cesser ses terres pour ça que j'en
souffre moins dépendre désormais aux
cuisines où ça criait très fort où on
pouvait même milliers d'éclats gurgy
jamais vécu ça moi en tout cas j'ai
jamais vécu ça et chez moi tout se passe
dans la discussion et dans le dans le
silence et la concentration c'est ce que
je dis souvent j'ai besoin de beaucoup
de concentration pourquoi aussi peu de
femmes à ce niveau-là de la cuisine
française
pour une raison très simple c'est parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut choisir
entre sa vie peut-être un peu familial
et personnel et puis un métier où on est
pris tous les soirs où c'est jeudi
c'est pour ça ce sens je c'est d'abord
c'est un métier physique il faut avoir
il faut avoir il faut avoir de
l'endurance il faut avoir une bonne
santé
et puis c'est vrai que ben comme je dis
on n'est pas là le soir pour raconter
l'histoire pour donner le bain et à un
moment donné bien il faut moi je veux
pas d'enfant
non pas encore mais j'espère que ça
arrivera un jour mais mais moi je sais
que avec moi j'ai des jeunes femmes qui
travaillaient
qui travaillent aujourd'hui et qui se
posent la question qui se disent moi je
voudrais trouver un travail en horaire
continu parce que ben je veux une vie de
famille aussi donc d un moment donné un
choix c'est ça ou c'est l'imagination
parce que j'ai noté des propos qui
étaient pas très sympa de deux bocuse je
crois je n'ai pas souvenance à qui avait
dit que grosso modo si les femmes et pas
plus en plus tu sais pas ce que c'était
pas très imaginative qu'elle faisait non
je me souviens de la musique de leur
contraire monsieur moque usa nous
encouragent énormément donc je précise
non non je pense que je pense que c'est
un moment donné c'est vraiment une
question de choix je pense qu'à un
moment donné on se dit c'est un
sacrifice qu'on fait quelque part la
cuisine que vous faites est ce qu'elle
est aussi imaginatif que celle des
grands chefs dont on dit quelquefois qui
font quasiment de la chine les plus de
cuisine moi c'est une cuisine très
cuisine et ça c'est certain c'est une
cuisine qui s'attacha à cuisiner les
choses à aller cuisine et même
longuement généreusement ça c'est
quelque chose de kim et ça après je le
fais avec ma personnalité avec des
émotions de manger dit c'est une cuisine
qui part de l'effort du ventre qui part
du coeur et chaque fois je dois bien sûr
de moi
outre ce n'est pas tellement apprises
mais à chaque fois c'est un peu de moi
qui pars à la fois mon éducation que
j'ai reçus dans les landes avec cette ce
goût des produits du sud-ouest et cetera
et puis ce respect de 2,2 du produit est
ensuite et ensuite tout mais expérience
et mon vécu
notre rêve c'est une troisième étoile ou
c'est un enfant d'abord c'est d'abord un
enfant sains
d'abord je vous